this fires really kicks your ass I
couldn't catch my breath I'm like oh my
god well first of all thank you for
doing this with us it's so nice to see
you I have to know how are you doing I
mean you had kovat with this virus we
don't really know if you still have it
because I live in New York and you can't
get tested here anymore
tests are not available even though they
say they are they're not my children and
my husband also had some minor you know
symptoms and even though they were
firsthand exposed they couldn't get
tested when I first started feeling sick
what happened was like I think was the
end of February my family all of us my
two teenage daughters and my husband all
held it's weird headache sore throat
low-grade fever it lasted like two days
it was weird that we all had the same
thing at the same time like that never
happens in my house like someone gets
sick okay we take care of each other
this is like all four of us are the same
weird symptoms at the same time and we
didn't think much of it do you know
where you got it well no I you'll never
know where you get a virus but I really
do believe I got it on the subway
because you know there's thousands and
thousands of people on the subway
constantly and you know I you're smashed
together I had been coughed on I mean I
was just normal when you live in New
York you like ill but you know I think I
mean I was even being very conscientious
not to touch anything but whatever I
mean I went to a hairdresser I went to a
nail technician I was preparing for
production because I was supposed to
start shooting season seven of younger
so is getting all ready that what this
all hit I just got a fever
I had 102 point 7 I had all the all the
symptoms like you know some of the
symptoms kind of rolled out like you
know you'd start out with a sore throat
headache then the fever and then body
aches and pains and then bite and I had
fever for 10 days and by the time
ten days was up I then I literally felt
it go into my chest like that the chest
all of a sudden got really tight so I
did a virtual doctor visit he prescribed
me albuterol which is a you know inhaler
that codeine cough syrup so I could
sleep at night and that cost you know
spores all over now you have to
understand that like I got tested and I
had to wait five days I went to Urgent
Care I saw that on your Instagram that
you couldn't get a test and then it was
five days to get the results of that
test yeah and I I was like what do you
mean I don't need a criteria I take the
subway I was in Italy and they know the
beginning in January who knows um I you
know I I don't understand why there is a
criteria if you have flu-like symptoms
and you're in a pandemic just to
estimate the chrissake so I walked into
Urgent Care and they tested me for flu
they shoved a q-tip thing up my nose I
swear ly reached my brain
I didn't just positive for a beef
influenza and then the köppen test is if
they're very thin kind of like wire with
a little swab at the end very soft and
that just goes down the back of your
nose and to the back of your throat they
were very nice to me at Urgent Care I
was very grateful I told people to go
there and they had no tests left like in
New York just it hit here like like a
tornado yeah and I had one evening of
where I had a bit of a panic attack
because I started coughing and I used my
inhaler and he kind of sent me to a
spasmodic cough and I started like and I
couldn't catch my breath and like oh my
god I got through it and then recovery
during that process by the way I was in
bed and I applied for to donate plasma
and a month later literally last week I
got
and even a phone call and they were like
you know can you come in I'm like yeah I
didn't think you're gonna copy they're
like no your number 7373 that's that's
what I we didn't get to you very late
everyone's calling to donate blood you
haven't taken a test though a second
time that determines yes negative so you
couldn't still technically have it or
you could still test positive yeah I
mean um there they will be giving me a
code which says I don't have any
symptoms I mean I had every symptom that
you've read about including the most
telltale one was losing complete loss of
taste and smell I've been doing all
types of stuff like taking lots of
immune boosters like zinc and oregano
oil I did a video thing with a Chinese
doctor I got like Chinese medicine that
they were using a lot in China to help
people recover are you worried at all
that you could get it again I'm really
not worried I feel like with viruses
generally if you get the flu one season
you don't get it again in the same
season I think I could definitely get it
again in the fall you know or maybe you
know I'm hoping I get it again before
they get that vaccine but your body
develops immunities and so I think I'm
better off than someone who hasn't had
it right I watched Governor Cuomo give
his press briefings almost daily do you
think that testing is getting a little
bit better in New York at this point
since when you got you don't even feel
it it's getting better no nobody can get
a test
I think Cuomo is doing an amazing job at
at least trying now to be strict and fix
the problem I mean the truth of the
matter is they didn't want to close the
schools they didn't want to close but
Madison Square Garden I was supposed to
take my daughter to a Philly Eilish
concert and I'm thinking of myself as oh
my god like I don't want to be around
20,000 screaming teenagers you know I'm
older I'm 55 you know I've been a smoker
I don't really want to be around all
these kids what am I gonna do why are
they opening up a huge venue like that
why are they making our kids get on the
subway I
that they acted a little bit too late
here because we are so congested and on
top of each other and they were not
following the protocol of what they do
in Italy or Spain
I don't know how with people opening up
states like Texas or Georgia opening up
a bowling alley like we really need a
bowling alley opens essential yeah yeah
I mean I cut my acrylics off like when
this first came down my nails are a
disaster together I'm gonna show you
mine you know having I haven't done my
color I'm kind of embracing it it's
great I'm gonna ask because I saw that
you posted that picture on Instagram
with the gray hairs coming in and I sort
of found a way to cover some of mine but
you see a little bit are you sort of
embracing this sort of natural way of
living are you loving it's kind of nice
I think um I don't love it I mean I'm
forced to embrace it I don't see here
kidding but like you know it's very it's
really coming in I'm letting it go
because I think it's really good to give
your hair a break yeah it is our hair is
very appreciative of this time right now
I feel like our bodies our skin yeah I
only put one when I'm doing these
because we're gonna make for the grant
here's like only I mean we could be like
pantsless now like you don't have to get
dressed
there's no PR chick there's no driver
waiting than the girl with the cell
phone like come on never you gotta get
in the car whatever like this is so
refreshing I have no hair and makeup
like your family no one else is
experiencing symptoms right now
everyone's okay everybody thank you know
they stopped having any symptoms like at
the end of February
oh wow okay so you know there's nothing
and they're strong do you have friends
who had this you're nothing you weren't
alone yeah I friends here friends in LA
friends in Italy oh yeah no I've known
many people in fact when I first
announced
on Instagram that I got the virus
and I felt like sharing because there
was I got it early and there was so much
unknown that I thought that maybe my
experience might help people and the
amount of comments that I've gotten
since then hundreds of thousands of
people are literally we're like thank
you oh my god this makes me I'm so
scared and you know they asked me
questions it's easy you just pick up a
twenty and you go like this
BAM I am obsessed with younger it is one
of my favorite shows season seven I know
that you said that you guys were gonna
go into production where were you in
production when everything got shut down
like hedges wardrobe fittings so you
hadn't shot anything no the scripts have
been delivered we had received the first
two scripts and I was supposed to go for
a wardrobe fitting next week the
Wardrobe people are already like at the
studio pulling stuff getting ready the
studio is you know the sets were being
built put back together my apartment
being put back together
yeah and so obviously the show usually
comes out in summer I think it's usually
around like June English when the season
yeah yeah
do you guys have an inkling of what the
timeline looks like like will it come
out this fall could it even be delayed
till next summer
oh god no um I think that you know we
need new contacts - everyone's been
watching everything so I think the TV
will come back before film and for sure
before theatres just because you know
film is locations figure people you know
in and out of buildings of TV you can
like take out all the big party scenes
you can rewrite the script you can shoot
and it's good a skeleton crew you know
there's ways actually to make that
happen
and I've heard rumblings like maybe
August September okay and then once you
shoot it I don't know when it comes out
that part I I never know I don't care I
don't even watch it so you don't watch
your own show no it's great
to watch it I why I watch it here in
there because I have to sometimes
repress I don't generally like watching
myself well I do have to ask you since
you have gotten the scripts there was a
big cliffhanger at the end of season six
I the Miller we marry me is there an
aunt fair least I know I feel like
virtual reunions right now we're all the
rage
everyone's doing them could you are
there talks of you doing one I mean
entourage younger cast Beethoven is now
streaming everywhere
I find you but what do you mean virtual
via I like getting the crew back yeah I
I will never do an entourage one because
we're all spread out actually
it's online right right III don't think
I mean a lot of those ships have sailed
I'd be more than happy to do anything
anybody wants me to do
[Music]